[Music]
bart
you no longer have your audi do you nope
i guess it any now true
okay i'm gonna show you guys these
there's these two photos it's around
that hour
you're gonna notice that audi's in it
okay okay
oh is this one of these photos where you
have to find the difference because of
the exact same photos but this is
nothing's missing
we're gonna play a game that's pretty
fun but it's not oh okay i don't care
this is the first one here we go
advertisement for audi oh
okay is that an rs5 uh rs
oh we were talking about cars the whole
time four rs4 oh it's a new one
on purpose i've never heard of rsv so it
must be new a new car rs4
they're they're promoting how how like
they
it has great performance but the reason
why you see
a child here is because they're like oh
but it's also gentle enough for you to
have this as a family car right
far away i thought that kid was a
traffic cone okay i see it
okay next photo tell me what you think
that's so funny tell me what you think
the kids all like styling you know
the kids kind of like that's my car foo
specifically geo what do you think
i don't know because my mind goes into a
dark corner let's hear that
thing wrong it just looks kind of like
why does she why is she eating a banana
wait is there something wrong with it
they're trying to wait you're thinking
that looks like
hold on i want to hear gio's thoughts
one second
it's just kind of weird like why she
it's they just kind of make her
less of a kid and like she's like a kid
adult like it just looks weird
okay and then you mention banana yeah
why is there a banana
you're thinking that that's like
[ __ ] well wait i just said
my mind can go into a dark space and she
wanted to hear the dark space so i want
to hear that
i gave it duffel yellow [ __ ] sucking
look at his hair
well i mean if you if you're talking
about a banana and the things that you
do to one that's
my mind didn't even go there because as
soon as it's in a kid's head i don't
think it's a dick anymore
that's perfectly fine that's perfectly
fine i was just trying to explore where
geo's mine
would have gone because generally i i
feel like most women would
probably view this and be like oh [ __ ]
that's that's not very
normal because from my mind it looks
perfectly okay
yes and that's fine because in my mind
it's like this
so like what's cute about it is this
kind of cool pose
you typically see a guy with a beer or a
guy with a cigarette
in this in this pose with the car kind
of like mr cool guy right but he's like
the kid's version because a kid can't
have it i would rather have like
juice boxes or ice cream yes juice box
there are two two things here that
rub people the wrong way the first one
the obvious one
is i know i did yes okay while she was
rubbing the computer
ah [ __ ] come on let me [ __ ] say this
okay so
the thing that really bothered people
initially is like would you have pointed
out the banana it's a little
suggestive it's a little odd you know
but
people hold on a lot of people on the
other side are like that's just
like kids kids eat bananas like that
literally bananas
kids ask for bananas all the time that's
their cigarette yeah
it was like jello but yeah all right so
that's the first thing right
and then another thing that a mom
actually pointed out was like oh my god
why would you have an advertisement
of a kid in front of the car like in
front of the girl that's like
the most dangerous thing i would never
tell my kids to do that like why are you
promoting this image
right so those are the two things
because the car's [ __ ] parked
but you don't even see the car but not
just that but it's kind of like well
it's what's cropping you want to like
even
let kids know that it's okay to even be
in front of a park car because it's
dangerous period
like you don't want marketing to the
kids it's like you know when you see
like uh
import tuner magazine are these moms are
like oh my god these abg's in front of a
honda civic
oh no don't run them over you know it's
like that's just
where you're the they're just poor tuner
yeah you're just [ __ ] in front of the
car
okay that you can totally view this from
an innocent lens and that's what
a lot of people viewed this from an
innocent lens but also a lot of other
people
were not viewing that and so they were
just pointing out how
sexually suggestive it was is just
really wrong that they should not be
putting children in these kind of
positions because usually
bananas are tied to something sexual
right
usually when it comes to when it comes
to
that joke like oh you don't want to like
be staring at anyone in the eyes while
you're eating a banana because it's
all kind of understood but the second
you go into like a child like universe
is the second you don't even associate
well that's what we all want to believe
okay
but there's a world of pedos out there
that would see this and get off on this
[ __ ] and that's the thing that people
are like
we have to not [ __ ] feed it is there
also a world of people that are like
wait so this
girl is she hates crips
she's repping bloods because she's right
in front of a red car you're gonna like
stretch to anything i think
you can stretch there too i think it's
no she actually
is wearing blue and she's stopping red
so she's confused do you think people
are mad that her dress is above the
knees
that's too that's too short you know
it's too crazy
so like it's like you can stretch to
find anything you want well it's not
just that but also the way she's leaning
on it
like usually when you see car
advertisements like what you said
usually it's women
promoting the car very sexually because
you're trying to attract men to come and
buy the car
but these are grown-ass women the fact
that they placed a female
child eating a banana in front of the
car
leaning on it it just it's like painting
too much
similarities to like grown women
promoting or like
modeling for cars right well and right
now too there's a there's a big
conversation
that i'm very happy about that starting
which is you know this
the sex trafficking child trafficking
being like 130
billion dollar industry in one of the
fastest growing industries so i think a
lot of people are kind of woke to that
so i think because that's already kind
of more sensitive yeah since it's
in the forefront of people's minds now
these types of things start popping out
even though
it could have been done very innocently
you know yes exactly
my viewpoint on this is similar to like
when we did the story of the karen that
went up to the girl who's taking
pictures in her bikini at the beach it's
like
yo like educate your own kids about
about whatever's going on rather than
like trying to tell other people what to
do
sure but i'm actually more on on on like
what
geo's saying here where it's like well
there's like a whole world of pedophilia
and like we don't know how what thing
how things go about like why would
major media outlets like advertisements
like just kind of
somehow like tiptoe around the lines of
that like i
i personally this is not in america
right this is audi so it's german
but they do advertisements in america
yes so in america though
they stay away from a lot of kids [ __ ]
though well not
in this so this was promoted through
twitter and then so they ended up
responding
and this is what they said so there's
three tweets i'll read them
it says we hear you and let's get this
straight
we care for children the audi rs4 is a
family car with more than 30
driver assistance assistant systems
including an emergency brake system
that's why we showcased it with various
family members for the campaign
we hope we could convey these messages
showing that even for the weakest
traffic participants it is possible to
relaxingly
lean on the rs technology that was a
mistake exclamation mark
audi never intended to hurt anyone's
feelings we sincerely apologize for this
insensitive
image and ensure that it will not be
used in the future
we will also immediately examine
internally how this campaign has been
created
and if control mechanisms failed in this
case so that's a response to that so
he's like what if they're like we just
wanted to show you
that this has so much stopping power
you could trust your [ __ ] kids to be
in the front and we will stop
the damn car that'd be such a turn i can
see it too from like the marketing
standpoint that's what i see it from
where it's just like
it's like your kids are comfortable now
and like they're just i think they just
oppose them to be like a little bit more
adulty like just like i'm cool like i'm
just chilling on my car you know like i
i do see it that way as well but the way
that i see it current climate of [ __ ]
you know
the way that i see it is so because
there's a series like a set of photos
so you have the same creative director
creating all these set of photos and
then so what i see from the first image
is almost like a cool hip modern family
and so it's a
it's a car for the cool hit modern
family so even the little girl or the
little kid
has swag she's just chilling with some
sunglasses on and a denim jacket
with buttons on it you know so that's
kind of just how i just that's how i
took it i never
i never really saw all the other uh
innuendos or anything i thought it was
like a like a
like a james dean kind of like a cool
ass like i didn't even think
yeah hot girl in front of car i thought
like kind of like a guy with a leather
jacket and then like a cigarette and
then like she's copying that
yeah so i see that it's crazy how a lot
of people can see so many different
things
i think it is important though to be
aware and be
sensitive to that aspect like
the social climate yeah i feel i feel
like if i was a parent i'd be like
[ __ ] this all these people getting mad
i'm gonna take my like a picture of my
own kid
staying in front of a car just be like
[ __ ] you guys yeah i think it's a little
bit of a slippery slope because i'm
trying to even like analyze
my own initial reaction to it and like i
would see the same thing i can imagine
being like
an assistant to the photographer on this
shoot and she's like oh my god that's so
cute that's adorable
and like leaving it simply but i guess
like maybe because you're also in it so
you understand the context
of what the marketing pitch was for this
whole concept
so so i guess even outside of that like
i don't naturally
i guess this is the slippery slope part
i don't naturally see the things that
may be jarring or offensive
but then the second somebody implants
those possibilities in my mind and how
like you know
in today's society or in like the pedal
industry or like
how that can be suggestive to blah blah
blah then
obviously a darkness kind of comes over
and it's like damn like
it taints it yeah and not just that but
just doesn't take that one
thing it takes the idea of things that
could be like this and then suddenly
let's say you're woke right everything
can be and then
that's just where the slippery slope
happens because
i i would have never seen it like that
unless like
i tried to you know what i'm saying so
it's not natural for me but now if i
want to be more woke to be more
sensitive it might make things
a lot darker and i think it's also
different um because i feel like
males just naturally don't go through
the same type of like negative
negative um encounters that females go
through so like
i think on a daily women will feel at
least like scared
of something at one point attacking them
or sneaking up on them
at least once a day like predatory like
feelings from
men like sexual predatory yeah so i
think we're just way more
uh danger sense is better yeah for
yeah protect my [ __ ] yeah because we
always have to be on guard you know like
we feel people's energies we see what
they're doing like and i don't think men
really
feel that you know exactly that's true
like
i don't think of that kid's giving head
when i look at that picture
and then maybe girls won't be perverted
but then they're more like
in tune with how someone else can be
perverted to that picture
yeah because we've experienced it
firsthand right so then this other
response to the tweets someone tweeted
this it said
took women two seconds flat faster than
the acceleration of my a7
to pick up on the disturbing innuendo
parentheses female child retired like
adult in front of red sports car eating
banana
more diversity in your marketing slash
management leadership these mistakes
what if it was a little boy
do you think it'll still be kind of
warning do you think it was because it
was a little girl
it's the it's like all of it combined
it's the girl the fact that she's a girl
the fact that she's eating
a banana that she's leaning on a car
which usually women
leaning on cart it's like you know
they're more sexual about it do you
think it would be
though yeah yeah [ __ ] on the hood
obviously there's like an extra
more extreme version of what this could
have been that you could easily write
off and be like well at least it wasn't
that
like obviously do you think your
motherly protection senses would come up
if it was a little boy
with like a jean jacket in a banana
would it be
different not as high it wouldn't be as
apparent
i see yeah it but it's definitely
the i don't think a child
needs to eat a banana in an
advertisement
to promote a car when it could easily be
replaced with like a
juice box or whatever is there a mom in
the first picture yeah
there's a mom dad and the kid and the
kids on the corner yeah
different kid though i think it's crazy
to me where like now it's like
no no one's allowed to eat a banana in
any kind of media
because now it's sexually suggestive you
know what i mean actually
kind of because even on this channel
there used to be someone that would sit
here and eat a banana and be like people
are like
they would comment and say that's pretty
distracting like can you
you guys just not do that you know
bananas are
funnily shaped like dick so phallic
haven't
talked about that yet what was yours
initial
like before like deep level scrutinizing
the ad though like when you just see it
it was nothing really but it wasn't
until like the question was
uh like how do you see it where it's
like okay so i need to tap into that
part of my brain but my initial wasn't
to go like oh
yeah i just saw i'm looking at the car
because that's what's
what my eye is trying to look at the car
and for me my
my my initial so i like i think everyone
views things with the initial bias first
my first initial bias is i'm a car
person i don't recognize that audi so
i'm like oh [ __ ] it's a new audi so it's
either rs5 or rs4 or something like that
and then my second bias is marketing
that's how i immediately think
so i'm so that's the order of how like i
examine things and then i'm like okay
cool i see what they're going for
rs4 is a small car which is generally
usually for women that's why they put
the guy at the forefront
just like how a lot of like trucks now
are are showcasing trucks with females
like
females can drive trucks guys can drive
small cars
kids could drive too so usually if they
have a guy a guy
so usually if they showcase a dad they
will put a daughter that's just
the natural like marketing of things to
balance things out and if they showcase
a mom the mom will be with the sun
so i understand all those marketing
things so i'm like i see why they chose
a daughter why they didn't put a son
to balance it all out but then i think
it's just there are but now if we look
at it
a couple layers deeper i can see where
people would be upset
but i'm also like there's also a set
formula that people follow
and it's just it's just it's just kind
of like i don't know it's tough
when the formula goes against everything
else
yeah yeah yeah i guess of the weird
things that now i'm like thinking of
like
people who are like if their kids are
eating bananas in public they're like no
no no go inside and eat the banana
people gonna look at you weird outside
like i don't know it's
i feel like it's like a part of normal
life so you're not censoring your normal
life so now you're just sensing and
you're sexualizing maybe you didn't grow
up like that
but girls grew up very censored we did
like
[ __ ] senses i mean i'm not saying it
doesn't happen right i'm talking about
like
in my own mind what i would idealize my
own world
right like i don't like the
being overly protected to the point
where it's like
unnecessary i understand why you think
that way because you didn't need to be
overly protected
you know what i mean like whereas for me
like if i wear a dress as a little girl
i see all my guy friends and i'm like
five six seven like a little girl
and i want to sit like this because
everyone's sitting like cross-legged and
it's fun and i would want you to sit
like that too
and i'm like no you can't you have to
always leave your legs closed like as a
girl and i'm like what the
[ __ ] like why you know what i mean
there's just so many little things where
it's like
um you you shouldn't be like like i
don't know you shouldn't be around this
boy or whatever
on men's laps yeah whatever like when
the little boy could easily run up to
the whatever an uncle and sit on the
left but as a girl no no you don't do
that yeah and it's like wait why why
can't he do it and i can't but it's like
because our parents or our moms
probably experience some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
where they're preventing us
from doing it but as a little kid you're
just like i don't get it like i just
want to play like tommy you know like
why do you have to treat me differently
but it's like
there's a lot of things that we're
trained to like pay attention to because
there's predators coming after
to get us you know so i i get why you
wouldn't think that way because you
didn't grow up that's true because then
girls always got to protect their [ __ ]
and they can smell out the in-cells
from just chill-ass dudes well i guess i
was looking for like in the progressive
mindset you know how like people it'd be
beautiful if i could feel
safe like all the time i mean like the
idea of the progressive mindset is like
the empowerment of women in these other
ways that's why like aoc is like big in
that now she's
sitting with her legs open and being
like in this power stance you know so
that's what the lens i'm looking at like
this
change that i hope is happening it is
happening but very very slowly yeah
because you don't see her walking around
topless all the time
like during the summer because guys do
that she can't do that still like she's
taking baby steps in new york you can
she is from new york maybe she does it's
legal
[Music]